hello oh welcome home honey come take a
seat you must be starving
yeah okay
congratulations on your fig win I didn't
know if you'd be in the mood for
meatloaf for lasagna so I made both
mom what's wrong why are you here
what do you mean I mean if you got
something you need to say to me
I'd appreciate if you just went ahead
and said it
okay
well thank you
cooking dinner both of them nope you're
welcome
you for not wanting to talk
excuse me thank you for flying all the
way here to come see me
you for not telling me you were coming
thank you for all the small silly little
things you did for me as a kid you know
like hiding notes in My Lunchbox or
putting googly eyes on the fruit at the
supermarket just to make me laugh and
you not working on yourself
we're seeking help after we lost dad and
for not talking to me about it either
just glossing over the whole thing and
acting like everything was all right
um sorry
um
I didn't know what to do Ted so
I pretended I was okay okay
well thank you for the apology
can you for making me think I had to
pretend to
all right I appreciate you sharing all
this with me
I just wish you hadn't carried it around
for so long
and uh
you're right Ted I do have something to
say to you
your son misses you
[Music]
I miss them too
she's like
it's like I'm scared
get close to that little boy
why
foreign
all right that is the thing about being
a parent
sometimes you lose and
sometimes you win but most the time you
just tie
all we can do
keep playing
[Music]
thank you
you